un match de basket
unique en france ce jeudi 6 février deux
écoles versaillaise sainte geneviève et
auch se sont affrontés dans un match
amical digne des plus grandes ambiances
universitaire américaine dans la salle
1600 supporters chauffés à blanc ouais
ouais c'est le mal sur l'année là on en
attend ça depuis deux mois
aulas a fait une semaine on pense plus
qu'à ça on a oublié toutes les maths
toute la physique et tout on est là pour
gagner
l amicale mais bon faut juste pas
complet
ce match de basket inédit a été créé il
ya une quinzaine d'années sur le modèle
des grandes rivalités universités anglo
saxonnes au rendez vous oppose
aujourd'hui des jeunes de 18 à 21 ans
mais ça reste avant tout des élèves de
classes préparatoires aux grandes écoles
donc qu'ils vont aller vivre à plus tard
polytechnique centrale et mina chaussée
mais là cet instant pour eux c'est un
partage sa souvenirs à vis à vis gravé
pour créer encore plus de souvenirs les
organisateurs ont vu les animations
grand dans ce gymnase mob auront
spectacle de pom pom girls mascotte d'un
soir speaker et star du basket français
ferait avec weiss ancien joueur de
l'équipe de france a fait le déplacement
depuis limoges spécialement pour
l'occasion
on m'a dit que c'était une ambiance de
folie pour un con je sois déçu j'espère
que ça va continuer c'est très bien pour
le basket suis très content alors bien
sûr il ya des rivalités mais moi je suis
pas dans ça j'ai vu comment dans
l'admiration parce que le match s'est
finalement terminée par une victoire de
l'équipe de ginette face à auch sur le
score de 65 à 46 pour l'année prochaine
les organisateurs prévoient un show
encore plus grand
[Applaudissements]